visite ça drôle de personnage drôle de
père noël pardon jean bafouille celui
que vous allez découvrir maintenant dans
son pays n'est pas une mince affaire que
de supporter à la fois un bonnet de
laine une barbe et une houppelande comme
il est convenu de dire reportage de
bernard benyamin et janry
rio en cette fin d'année 1985 il
s'appelle victor il a 40 ans et
s'apprête à vivre pendant quinze jours
une épreuve pour le moins redoutable
jouer le rôle du père noël sous les
tropiques en fête pour victor cet emploi
est arrivée à point nommé il va lui
permettre de faire vivre sa famille
pendant un certain temps
en tout cas de lui assurer de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année et si possible
d'acheter des jouets pour ses enfants
car victor comme plus de 20% de la
population active au basilic et au
chômage
en principe je suis électricien mais
actuellement je ne trouve pas de travail
c'est pourquoi j'ai accepté de jouer le
père noël pendant quinze jours on me
paye 60 milles couverts par jour c'est à
dire environ 40 francs et tout ce que je
souhaite c'est que l'année nouvelle
m'apporte un nouvel emploi
la température a déjà monté lorsque
victor commence à tourner payé par un
groupe de commerçants d'une grande
artère de rio il doit se promener dans
la rue
engager la conversation avec les enfants
et invité les parents à visiter les
boutiques
et elle n'est que déjà vu la neige non
la neige gelée jamais vu sauf à la
télévision surtout au moment de noël
ici on a pas de neige pour noël comment
fait-on eh bien nous en rions n'a pas de
neige dans le sable sur la plage
image surréaliste d'un père noël sur la
plage
mais c'est vrai qu'il en faut du courage
pour jouer les père noël dans cette
fournaise
alors que la mer est toute proche victor
ne résistera pas très longtemps du reste
pour son premier jour de travail il va
se permettre un petit extra et sous
l'oeil aguerri et un peu déçu des
enfants le père noël va se transformer
en nageurs accompli mais avouez qu'il
est bien difficile pour un père noël de
supporter 38 degrés à l'ombre
naturellement